c'est quoi ça le gars qui a mis ces
images en ligne dit qu'elle vienne d'une
cassette qui l'a trouvé dans la forêt de
black hills je crois que ça pourrait
être ma soeur
tu crois vraiment que tu as heures pour
être encore là après toutes ces années
si j'ai la moindre chance de découvrir
ce qui lui est arrivé je dois essayer
selon la légende cette forêt auraient dû
nous dit vous croyez aux histoires sur
la saucière de blair
ça vous dit quelque chose
on est en train de tourner en rond
y'en a partout car ce genre de récit toi
qui à fait tort
m
et
mais pas tous
on l'a trouvé
peut pas être ça
mais la bagarre
à
sortie
inc
soit
dommage